startling news on the coronavirus and
the president of the united states
we now all know that president trump
intentionally downplayed the threat of
the pandemic for months
potentially worsening the severity of
this crisis on march
19th it's on tape president told
journalist bob woodward quote
i wanted to always play it down i still
like playing it down because i don't
want to create panic
for months after that he compared the
virus to a flu
while privately noting that it is more
deadly than even the most strenuous flus
and since then the u.s death toll from
the coronavirus has risen
from 265 to more than 190 thousand
health experts say with stronger
restrictions many of those deaths could
have been prevented
it's one of many revelations in
woodward's new book rage which is
published by simon schuster
a division of viacom cbs paula reed is
at the white house for us she's been
following this paula good morning to you
how is the president responding good
morning
tony president trump is addressing this
controversy head-on yesterday
he took questions from reporters where
he defended his actions
but now he's also disparaging bob
woodward even though over the course of
seven months he sat down for 18 on the
record interviews with the legendary
journalist
woodward says he approached this
assignment the same way he approached
his work in watergate
he wanted to know what the president
knew and when he knew it
on february 7 bob woodward spoke to the
president
who had just talked with chinese
president xi jinping the day before
in audio recordings obtained by the
washington post
mr trump admitted to woodward the
severity of the virus
it goes through air bob that's always
tougher than the touch you know the
touch you don't have to touch things
right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's uh passed
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flus this is
more deadly this is
five per you know this is five percent
versus
one percent and less than one percent
you know so
this is deadly stuff our country is
stronger today
even after acknowledging the virus was
airborne the president held at least
seven indoor rallies and despite knowing
the flu was not more deadly
mr trump continued to say otherwise
we're finding very little problem
very little problem now you treat this
like a flu
by downplaying the threat americans lost
time to prepare
we're prepared and we're doing a great
job with it and it will go away just
stay calm
it will go away then in march mr trump
told woodward the virus was a threat to
younger americans
now it's turning out it's not just old
people bob just today and yesterday
some startling facts came out it's not
just old old
yeah exactly people to plenty of young
people but then in the following weeks
the president was urging states and
schools to reopen
saying this we'd like to see the schools
open early next season and
on time it's incredible how the
it's very unique how the children are
affected
and in a shocking admission on the same
day the death toll in the united states
reached 265
the president volunteered to woodward
that he was intentionally misleading the
country
well i think bob really to be honest
with you sure i want you to i wanted to
[Music]
i wanted to always play it down i still
like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic one study from may estimates that
shutdown delays in the early days of the
pandemic could have cost up to 54
thousand lives
we would have had a stay at mandate put
in place all of which we did and we did
it about as early as any american state
but we would have done it earlier and
undoubtedly would have saved lives
but on wednesday the president doubled
down on his decision to lie about the
severity of the virus
the fact is i'm a cheerleader for this
country i love our country
and i don't want people to be frightened
i don't want to create
panic as you say mr trump's democratic
rival
former vice president joe biden blasted
the president
he knew how dangerous it was now while
this deadly disease ripped through our
nation
he failed to do his job on purpose
it was a life-and-death betrayal of the
american people
the president says he did not want to
invoke fear but throughout his campaigns
and
this administration the president has
repeatedly leaned into people's fears
about immigration
crime even low-income housing now
woodward who is still associated with
the washington post is also facing some
criticism
and questions about whether he should
have published this evidence that the
president was trying to downplay
a deadly pandemic sooner woodward
responded to questions about that
yesterday saying that
he wanted time to be able to vet the
president's statements more thoroughly
before publishing them anthony paula
thank you